all right looks like we're now live for
the
November uh
2023 ask me anything session we've
already got a few questions lined up so
I am going to take those uh here's an
interesting one from Zach I'm a
professor of philosophy now uh
pedagogically thoughts on getting
students reinvested in class after
feeling like losing them so you know
there's a couple things to be said about
that that's actually kind of a a great
question uh the first thing to say is
well you don't really know if you've
lost them or not because you you
sometimes have the experience of having
a student come up to you later on and
saying oh I've been thinking about that
thing that you were talking about I
didn't say anything in class because I I
didn't feel like I had anything useful
to say at that time but now I've been
mulling it over so you're never quite
sure what seeds you've planted in their
minds pedagogically right um but let's
let's say that you actually have lost
them you know and and you haven't lost
them forever right because they're going
to come back and um keep you know taking
CL ass with you so I think part of what
you can do or maybe two two important
things one is to reconnect and reinforce
what you were talking about
before and you can say to them you can
be very honest you can be like you know
I think I I lost a lot of you when we
were talking about you know K groundwork
because you didn't seem to be responding
to it at all um it's kind of
understandable it's complicated
difficult material here's some of my my
own thoughts that I've had you know
since our class session uh I'd like to
just go back to this thing and and you
know highlight this passage and what
you're doing them there as you're
showing them that philosophy and really
the humanities in general aren't just
like this modular thing where we do a
bit of this over here and then we do a
bit of this over here and and none of
it's all you know interconnected to each
other and you know you're showing them
you're modeling for them how
to keep on thinking about something so I
think that could be quite helpful um and
then you know the other thing that you
can do to involve your students a little
bit more coming back to that material is
you know see if you can have them think
of problems or examples or you know raw
material that you can then work on and
say well you know maybe the answer is
already brought up by this person in
this this text right
um and so you know if you get them a
little bit more involved in it then you
know even if you did lose them you can
you can bring them back so that's kind
of good uh Angry archaeologist
historical methodologies is it helpful
to contrast Marx's materialist
Progressive cause effect economic equals
political with hegel's concept of
History nonlinear unique social
Arrangements I mean I'd say both of
those are actually wrong um as as stated
but yeah you can compare anything you
like it's a free country um you just
kind of want to make sure that you're
actually getting them correct it's not
like Marx is totally linear and Hegel is
nonlinear they're both you know they
both view history as having some
impasses and then getting past that and
you know they're approaching it in
different ways but yeah you
can you can um compare and contrast
whatever you like the question you know
asking is it helpful helpful is a
relative term helpful for what helpful
for writing a you know thesis helpful
for understanding the world we live in
helpful for exercising your mind I mean
it could be helpful for all sorts of
things but that is not something there's
no like helpfulness per se out there
that we have as a Criterion for for
something
so all right let's take uh Kevin Kevin
Sullivan this is probably a common
question but what current living
philosophers are breaking new ground
again depends on what you mean by
breaking new ground right
um I mean Alistair McIntyre is still out
there working urgen Hoss is still out
there working Martha nbal is still out
there working to what degree are they
breaking new ground it kind of depends
on what you mean by that you know um
does McIntyre's you know latest thing uh
hopefully he'll be around for you know
past a hundred because he's in his 90s
that he brings out uh the latest thing
is it's something radically new well we
don't need radically new as a matter of
fact the more radically new something is
the more likely it is to be not
particularly good you want it to build
off of things that we already have do we
have you know um new ground in
interpretation of historical figures all
the time I mean look at how helenistic
philosophy has come to be
rethought uh by so many figures in the
last half century and that's still going
on now so I mean if you're looking for a
catalog of like who are the the hot new
philosophers I'm not the guy to come to
for that because I don't jump on to
Trends um but there's plenty of people
doing interesting work out there in the
present um you just kind of have to look
around for them all right uh huzifa says
I want to formerly learn philosophy but
can't afford to go to a university for
that what are some
Alternatives uh this is purely for
having a deep understanding of
philosophy I'm a medical student well um
so you know if you can't afford to do it
then you you might not be able to afford
like studying with somebody
independently because there's plenty of
us out there who offer tutorial services
or online classes or things like that so
then you know you're you're thinking
more about um other free Alternatives or
very inexpensive Alternatives so you
have the entire world of the internet
out there in front of you
and um now there's no substitute for
actually reading the texts and studying
them but you know if you want to know
about most um interesting
philosophers there are videos out there
there are podcast episodes you can find
quality uh writings on them secondary
sources you know for example in the
Internet Encyclopedia philosophy or the
Stanford encyclopedia philosophy you
have all sorts of blogs you have all
sorts of um cool stuff that's available
really for free or for a minimal cost I
mean some of these things may cost you
like $5 dollar a month or something but
you know you can you can easily do those
um and then you know the other thing I
would say is if you if you're interested
in something in
particular you want to look around for
online communities of people who are
interested in that same thing so for
example if you were interested in
stoicism um stoic week is going on
starting Monday and you know that that's
a great thing to do even if you know a
little bit about stoicism already and
then you know there are week not weekly
there are monthly sessions uh you know
that are held by the modern stoicism
organization just got to go to their
their uh
page or YouTube channel and they're
called conversations with modern stoics
so like next time it's Christopher Gil
who is a major thinker uh in helenistic
philosophy and a great guy all around
and I'll be there for that as somebody
participating in the audience you know
uh because I want to hear what Chris Gil
has to say and so there's all sorts of
opportunities to participate but you you
have to do some some work you have to do
some research and tracking these things
down uh you'll be surprised just how
much is actually out there available for
you again largely for
free all right
um Sylvio says my question is about
Hegel I don't understand his insistence
on
determinacy specifically in the
phenomenology of spirit I get that it's
meant to support systematic thought but
I don't understand why I think you might
be confusing
yourself um there's no necessary
connection between systematic thought
and determination not determinacy but
determination btim right um one of the
things that you see Hegel doing in his
dialectical approach to things and and
he's not the only one to do this of
course I mean this is something that
goes way way back to like
Aristotle is saying that okay we can
talk about you know abstract ideas but
what happens when they actually get put
into play and practice in real life you
know what happens when they become you
know to use another hegelian term actual
or real via Clique right um how does
that you know how does that change or
reveal things about the idea that we're
working with and you know uh I don't
know that that supports systematic
thought um but you know it's certainly
if you want to be systematic and you
want to be engaged with reality which
Hegel certainly does um then you have to
pay attention to how things do in fact
get determined but I wouldn't get I
wouldn't get tripped up on trying to
figure out what's the connection between
these things with Hegel probably the
best bit of advice that I can give for
you is when you get tripped up and
you're reading through say the
phenomenology of spirit keep on reading
see where it goes because nothing has
ever fixed and solved and like you know
here's my Doctrine once and for all uh
at any one single point in the work it's
it there's a lot of moving parts so to
speak and we have to put them all
together all right um Anthony summer
says how has your mathematics background
helped or hindered your philosophical
growth research or understanding of
philosophy um I mean I went through a
phase that a lot of people
I think do whether they have a
mathematics background or they're just
enamored of mathematics uh where I
thought that you know maybe mathematics
could in fact be the key to to
understanding and
formulating everything um you know been
good company with that I think about you
know Renee deart uh in his early years
or go freed vham livets right and then
you come to realize that mathematics is
you know a great set of disciplines
there's no such thing by the way as
mathematics per se there's all these
different mathematical disciplines that
are interconnected with each other and
tend to have a common approach to to
matters um and you know you you start
seeing the limitations of adopting what
you can call a formalist approach to to
matters that would frame everything in
terms of functions and you know
computation I mean it's great to
actually get to learn the limitations
because then you're not taken in by all
these AI uh Hawkers who are like AI will
solve everything the algorithm because
you're like yeah that's that's not we're
we're not Advanced to the degree that
people are putting forward and even if
we were there's still going to be
problems with relying upon formal
systems to to do that but I I love
studying uh mathematics I mean I I got
into it in college in part because my
calculus one class that I got thrown
into freshman
year we began with the theory of limits
which is very philosophical I mean
there's lots of interconnections between
mathematics and and philosophy and then
I got into studying logic and you know
not in a a sort of superficial way but
in a pretty uh deep way you know reading
the the you know Cutting Edge stuff that
was available in journals at the time
and thinking about the the nature of
logic and how it could be you know
connected with our actual language and
thinking that we use and that was very
useful for me I would say I don't know
that it would be for everybody you know
uh as we grow our studies are you know
incorporating the the different things
that we're studying and and how we're
learning it because you know you can
study mathematics at one place
and you'll still study the same Concepts
and material and applications but the
way that it gets taught to you and
connected to other things might be very
different in another place so we have to
be kind of careful about
overgeneralizing about uh individual
instances all right uh zubay Mir what's
the difference between existentialism
and absurdism in simple words sir um
well I I'm not going to give you simple
words because uh we're doing philosophy
here and uh demanding that people put
things into simple words is sort of like
asking for them to give you what you
actually don't want but don't realize
that you don't want so existentialism
can be understood in in several
different ways right uh as can absurdism
I mean absurdism can be as trivial as
people bullshitting around and just like
saying random stuff uh by the way people
also used to do that and and claim that
they were doing Zen as well right very
popular in the 80s and early 90s but if
we want to be more technical about it
absurdism is a movement largely I mean
you could say it goes back to you know
19th century thinkers as well you might
even trace it back further but it's
largely a 20th century and 21st century
movement and often gets associated with
somebody like um Albert kamu who claimed
he wasn't an existentialist and we'll
get to that in just just a moment um
that he was engaging in a philosophy of
the Absurd he never calls himself an
absurdist which other people do in fact
call him and other authors call
themselves
absurdists but you know um
existentialism is a broader category and
it includes absurdist like Albert kamu
um depending on what you mean by
existentialism if you're looking at like
say the myth of
Copus then look at who he defines as an
existentialist he says kirkgard yaspers
shesto you know Kafka to a certain
extent right uh dooi to a certain extent
but he doesn't lump n in there and he
doesn't talk at all about sart um or
debir or I don't even think he talks
about Gabriel Marcel in that either in
point of fact existentialism is a broad
loose movement that includes even people
who say that they're not existentialists
because we've rightly in philosophy
identified them as um fitting into the
existentialist Pantheon or whatever you
want to call it the existentialist
Spectrum so an absurdist like Albert
kamu um is actually an existentialist as
well an existentialist in the broad
sense not in the sense that he defined
finds it over and against his own
stuff same thing with Jean Paul sart
just going the other way he tries to
give a um definition of existentialism
that a lot of other existentialists
don't actually agree on that you know
it's the doctrine that existence
precedes essence and here's what I mean
by it right
um well s doesn't get to claim that
space right and so Gabriel Marcel who's
the first person to actually use the
term existentialism in French has just
as good of a claim to it as sart does um
even though you know Marcel will say
yeah sorry you can have the word I'm G
to call what I'm doing Christian
socratism so you know is there really a
difference the difference between
existentialism and absurdism there isn't
um think of them as overlapping with
each other to a very significant extent
um in part because they're both loose
movements and you don't want to tie
yourself in with like rigid well
existentialism over here absurdism is
over here there's a nice neat dividing
line there isn't and that's the way it
actually works for a lot of isms in
philosophy I'll say uh just to bring
this this to a
close all right John
says uh good evening from Norway when
you studied ancient Greek did you read
any poetry either epic lyric or pastoral
poetry do you any favorites yeah I mean
we we read selections of poetry um and
poetry includes uh dramatic you know you
got epic lyric and I mean they don't
actually have a category uh back then of
pastoral uh poetry that's sort of a
modern uh um thing that would basically
fit under lyric as far as I understand
um but you know dramatic poetry uh the
comedies and tragedies you know and um
yeah I mean we we read uh Homer uh spent
an entire semester on the Odyssey um and
you know read other stuff as well I mean
I I read quite a bit of Solen because I
was interested in h political philosophy
and he wrote a lot of his stuff as lyric
poetry you know so yeah I mean you you
when you're studying as a student what
you do first is like learn the grammar
and some vocabulary and then you start
reading short passages and then you'll
take like semester long classes with
with people studying an author like I
you know I think I got to
do five semester long reading classes
one was on Plato Symposium one was like
I said Homer Odyssey uh Herodotus uh the
you know the history um Aristotle's
nicam McAn ethics then we had another
class where we read um um
Plato's uh Li what did we read the uh
The Credo we read uh some of lucius's
speeches and we
read um ol lucian's true history right
so and you know you also get some like
parody of poetry in there as well
because like Plato is you know
constantly mentioning poetry right so he
brings up poetic passages has people
like often use them almost like
fundamentalists do with proof texting
well Homer says or simones says right
you see this a lot in in Plato So then
you read it in in the uh the little
couplet or passage there all right
um burn Grace what do you think of
Badu's interpretation of Plato I don't
think anything of Badu's interpretation
of Plato because I don't spend really
any time reading
Badu uh
he's there's so many contemporary
authors that uh I don't I don't stay on
top of
that um Sans C says uh do you know of
any good contemporary works that apply
stoic philosophy to issues of
racism um not off hand but I mean it's
it's pretty straightforward you know a
stoic is going to be Against Racism
because they consider Humanity as a
whole to be the human race right and
um you know it's interesting because
when we talk about the
indifference um the class of things in
the middle that don't have you know
moral goodness or moral Badness to them
but have some sort of limited value one
of the examples that the stoics would
actually use of something that is truly
indifferent is the color of a person's
skin whether black or white they were
like that doesn't matter at all um you
know and you could say well people were
you know ethnocentric back then yeah but
not in the same way that we are today
where people like to talk about a white
race or stuff like that um I mean the
stoics would look at racism as being a
form of
Injustice and uh I mean it's kind it's a
good thing to know because um there's a
lot of uh right-wingers who want to try
to use bits and pieces of things from
ancient philosophy
and as soon as you start studying the
ancient philosophy you realize that
these people haven't studied and they're
full of crap and you know the ancient
philosophy would actually go against
their their point of view you know um
and stoicism is a great example of that
to be a stoic um you would need to be
committed to
cosmopolitanism to an entire
Commonwealth of of you know human beings
and then if we believe in Gods of gods
as well this is a consistent stoic
Doctrine and that uh um you know
discriminating against people on the
basis of
irrational uh distinctions that don't
really make any serious moral difference
is evil and unjust so but is there
contemporary literature out there about
that I mean I don't know I mean
Christopher Gill's latest book which I
don't have my hands on because it's kind
of expensive might might actually
consider that
so all right um let's see here Ben Fels
says as a
writer how do you overcome the feeling
that everything you want to write about
has been written and better by somebody
else this is clearly an unhelpful and
untrue mindset to have okay so um part
of what can help you there is that last
sentence this is clearly an unhelpful
and untrue mindset to have and the
untrue is the important part um and we
could add to that unverifiable I mean
how would you possibly know that in
advance that anything that you are going
to write has already been written by
somebody
else um that seems a very very strong
claim to make and now like you said it
corresponds to a
feeling um but it doesn't make that a
true claim just because we have that
feeling
um so
you know questioning that can be quite
helpful and then you know thinking about
okay what do we mean by already been
written by somebody else somebody else
has said the exact same words that's
pretty unlikely somebody else has
already address the topic well so what
that doesn't mean that they exhausted
the topic or they've talked about it in
the only one true legitimate way to talk
about it you know I mean I talk about
cats all the time human beings have been
living with cats you know since
prehistory and people have written in
awful lot of things about cats but that
doesn't mean that every time that I talk
about you know sassy and the special
relationship that we hadn't developed or
why that after her death that leads me
to volunteering at almost home cat
shelter that somebody else is out there
writing about that as a matter of fact
um I I probably need to do more writing
about that sort of thing uh because
there hasn't been enough writing about
it that that you know could reach people
and tell them hey it's okay to grieve in
this way and you don't need to replace
your animal with another animal you can
do something else instead right um so
you
know you you can think that you you
don't have to bring something unique or
you know completely un you know unheard
of to to the table in order for it to be
valuable you know um so you might
actually get more mileage out of like
thinking okay what isn't getting enough
attention what could I write about that
people would benefit from learning or or
hearing
so all right uh Mark hey good to see you
here I hope you are all well and have a
good month ahead uh question favorite
monster from any
media favorite monster um oh that's
that's kind of good I
mean I am teaching Frankenstein again in
one of my classes Mary Shell's
Frankenstein and if if for any of you
who haven't read that book so there's
you know the monster and the monster is
actually a a
conscious um
thoughtful morally amb
ambiguous but rational being who has a
lot of interesting things to say and I
think Mary Shelly did a pretty good job
you know it's interesting my students
are like they're not they're not doing
the easy thing you know Frankenstein is
the true monster they're more like
Frankenstein is really a jerk I mean he
creates this thing and then you know
when it it comes alive he's surprised
that he's been successful and he swoons
and you know he's revengeful towards it
and he he goes back on his promise to
create a a fellow creature and all that
so I mean Frankenstein's monster in the
original is pretty good not the stupid
you know fumbling around animated corpse
that movies have made it out to
be um I mean we get a lot of
cool let's look at things from the
perspective of the monster
literature in um speculative fiction
throughout the years you know so but I I
guess maybe Frankenstein is
it
um Jonathan says how should I go about
getting a master's in philosophy I have
a bachelor's in another field well the
first thing you'd have to do is start um
researching programs where you would
want to apply
because um if just talking about the
American situation here we have you know
hundreds of places you could go and
study and get a master's in philosophy
and they don't all do the same thing
they don't all have the same curriculum
they don't even all have the same
entrance uh admission standards some of
them aren't going to be interested in
you without a bachelor's degree in
philosophy some of them aren't going to
be interested in you period because of
you know weird vagaries like they're
looking for people who are interested in
this this semester or you know the
professors can't get along like when I
applied at actually for graduate school
one of the places that I was accepted to
wrote me back and said uh we had a big
fight between professors in our
department and so many of them left that
now we can't offer the program that we
were call back in a couple years that
was depal University when they
essentially booted all the analytic
philosophers out in the Continentals
took over so you want to like research
you want to like look into the places
that you might be interested in you
should contact them right away there'll
be somebody who's called a director of
Graduate Admissions and you can ask them
okay I don't have a degree in philosophy
hopefully you have a degree in something
that's close to it you know like history
or English or one of the other
Humanities um what would I need to do to
get into the program and they might tell
you well you need a you need a ba um or
they might say well we'll take you in
provisionally but you're going to have
to take some makeup classes some 400
level classes where uh seniors and
graduate students can take them because
you need to have a background in this
this and this and this right that might
be what they they end up um recommending
or requiring for you so you know it it
really depends quite a
bit all right
um save self is someone who recently
learned about formal systems I deeply
appreciate this discussion on
mathematics uh yeah uh back Moon which
of dared DA's writings do you think are
worth reading and which do you think
aren't and which insights do you think
he has so I think dared DA's early work
is quite rigorous and well worth reading
and I think there's some great insights
not all of which are as Earth shaking as
they were made out to be at the time
like there's nothing outside of the text
yeah no [__] you know I mean everything
is tied up with language in in one way
or another you're never going to get
something that's purely outside uh
language at least for us human
beings um but it you know it's cool what
what he does I mean I I got attracted to
DAR because I was kind of doing what he
was doing without knowing that it was D
derian deconstruction you know with
saying okay we got you know various
systems here how can the system actually
say something about itself within the
system you know it's part of what
deconstruction does right and
deconstructions answerers it only does
so imperfectly right so on grammatology
really big early book uh Speech and
phenomena a little bit before that um uh
writing indifference those are sort of
like the early three that you should
start with and then Dara has all these
other works where maybe you're maybe
you'd find him interesting maybe you'd
find him to be a waste of time like I I
think his book on Hegel not GL not even
worth bothering with um but you know
occasionally has some interesting
insights along the way way um and then
you know towards the end of his life
like maybe the last decade and a half he
becomes very interested in in questions
that he hasn't adequately considered of
politics and religion and he comes out
with a whole bunch of pretty good books
they they could have used some
editing um because they're all mostly
lectures you know like the gift of death
and specters of marks and the politics
of friendship right that's pretty good
stuff
um and uh you know he's he's kind of
insightful in that he realized long
before the rest of us that the issue of
hospitality and immigration is going to
become massive uh in terms of uh
political issues in ways that we didn't
realize and he was writing about this in
the early to mid 90s so you know that
that's good all right um who framed the
Socratic method do you have a favorite
short story I don't have favorite really
much of
anything uh there's I think you
know as you get
older
um and your experience
broadens you find that you you have
things you really like but they're not
your favorite in the sense of like um
ruling out other things is as being on
their same level like I don't have a
favorite band although I can tell you
who I really like I don't have a
favorite meal although I can tell you
the ones that I really like and I don't
have a favorite short story although I
can tell you the ones I really like and
I don't have a favorite philosopher
either you know but some can be higher
up and some can be lower
down all right William Zen says I'm
reading friederick NCH I cannot
understand most of what I read should I
rely on secondary sources like like
Frederick Cobblestone or keep plowing
through the works of n well I think the
first thing you want to do is think
about um why and what you're not
understanding and um that'll help you
figure out what you ought to do I mean
maybe I mean if you're just jumping into
nich as like your first philosopher that
you're reading he's making all these
Illusions to other philosophers so
you're not going to know what the hell
he's saying right um he also does things
in a very uh convers
pical sort of way maybe that's not a
style that you're you're used to um he
also doesn't value consistency and maybe
you you know really demand consistency
out of an author right so you want to
think about why you're not understanding
things there's nothing wrong with
reading secondary literature um you
don't want to remain content with just
relying on secondary literature because
you don't actually know whether the
secondary literature is getting the
author right until you go back to the
author but there's nothing wrong with
reading you know Cobblestone or I mean
if you want to get a wrongheaded thing
uh ber and Russell's history of
philosophy
um you know there's plenty of other
n people out there that you could read
um so you know yeah nothing nothing
wrong with that but again I I think you
want to think about why you're having
trouble with it and realize too that n
is not an easy author right maybe what
you are uh confusing with having a
general idea you you know you actually
do understand it more than you realize
but you don't understand it fully right
and you're confusing understanding it
fully with uh not understanding it at
all right
so all right mage of War I homeschooled
my children do you think teaching them
medieval logic would be advantageous or
disadvantageous to their
development I mean why would it possibly
be disadvantageous I mean unless you're
teaching it in terrible ways which a lot
of homeschoolers probably do because
they think you know I mean depends on
why you're homeschooling right I mean
let's be honest about that a lot of
homeschooling is actually kind of just I
don't want my kids in the public schools
and you know it's culture War kind of
stuff and people like that make terrible
teachers I think um but if you're
actually homeschooling your kids because
you want them to get a great education
why would you possibly not introduce
them to a topic like uh medieval you
know authors on logic and you know keep
in mind there is no medieval logic out
there there's a whole bunch of different
authors doing different things and
they're not all you know on the same
level so if somebody's selling you a
medieval logic textbook and it based
basically is just warmed over Aristotle
stuff and you're not actually reading
say Peter abelard or buthus or people
like that now you got a problem right um
but you know there's nothing wrong with
in incorporating that I mean don't
pretend that logic it translates
automatically into real life and if
you're gonna do logic you probably also
need to teach them you know literature
which is part of uh the Trivium you know
under grammar um and uh rhetoric as as
well right so all right uh Max monu how
do you think H tugan Lara of his
metaphysics and morals roughly fits into
and adds to his ethical philosophy
unfortunately there's few resources for
helping to understand the work so let's
let's start out Tuan Lara you don't have
to call it that just call it the The
Virtue portion right because that's what
the tugan there means and Lara just
means teaching so the metaphysic PHS of
morals which is what the groundwork of
the metaphysics of morals is the
groundwork too has two parts the
metaphysical uh uh elements of right
social philosophy political philosophy
metaphysical elements of virtue you know
more personal stuff um I think it's
actually that's one of his easiest works
it's very straightforward I think hant
is you know good in explaining stuff
there um the whole point of the
groundwork is to be the ground work for
the metaphysics of morals right it's
where he starts getting much more uh
clear and specific about what does
ethics actually really look like um the
groundwork is great the second critique
is awesome but the metaphysics and
morals is is the actual ethical
philosophy so you know that's uh how
does it fit into an add to the ethical
philosophy it is the ethical philos
philosophy it doesn't it fit into an and
to it it is you know where he's actually
telling you what he thinks virtuous or
righteous Behavior looks like you know
there's one other book that I would say
is particularly important in terms of
kant's ethics and it's kind of a to a
lot of people it's going to sound like a
weird one religion within the limits of
reason alone which is about religious
topics but is also very much about
ethics because Kant effectively turns
you know his conception of good religion
into into ethics so yeah all right um
Tashi what are some texts that a
philosophy student read concerning
gender transsexuality gender gender
fluidity I read Butler's work and I
found the con concept of performa
performativity
interesting I don't know because that's
not an area that I really specialize in
I mean um there's probably a vast
literature out there um Butler of course
is pretty important because of her
notion of performativity I mean I think
you could go back
into um earlier feminist authors and say
what would what would what they have to
say for example in Simone de bvar second
sex can there be a third sex you know
how do these things play out in an
existentialist perspective right
um so you know
um I I I don't really know I I don't
have recommendations about that sort of
thing um but maybe somebody else out
there
does um Westwood what was one of the
most profound things you read about that
got you into
philosophy well there wasn't any one
single thing that got me into
philosophy um you know my my history
with it is thinking about things quite a
lot as a kid and not thinking about it
being told that counts his philosophy
and then later on finding out that um
there was this discipline out there
called
philosophy and uh you know taking a a
particularly bad philosophy class in
high school an intro to philosophy and
then taking a really good uh not
actually build as philosophy but
effectively philosophy class and I've
written about that you can find that out
there on the the the net very easily A
Tale of Two philosophy teachers is the
article name um and I I think basically
what got me into thinking about
philosophy was probably speculative
fiction you know thinking about
metaphysical and epistemological and
moral
themes within that are that are raised
within these stories by very smart
authors like what's the nature of the
universe you know or can we actually
know things for certain uh uh or can we
just have probabilities that we rely
upon or what's what's the right thing to
do or how should Society be organized
but I I can't like pinpoint any one
particular book that that Drew me in you
know and I'd say maybe music also kind
of figured into that as well you know um
thinking about the things that were
framed in terms of
um lyrics and in songs right Alfonso
says you have frostbites on your hand no
I have cat cat scratches on my hand I
volunteer at a cat
shelter and some of the cats will play
rougher than than others um but I'm
never looking for advice about any
health related matters so always resist
the temptation to give unasked for
advice uh mm recommend a book on
irrationalist
philosophy um I mean if we're just going
to pull crap out of the air um we talked
about n a little bit earlier some people
think of n as an irrationalist Beyond
Good and Evil there you go um
Wonderbread do you have any favorite
philosophy book covers aesthetically no
again I I actually don't pay much
attention to book covers um I typically
take them off of hard cover books
because I I just they get in the way for
me um and I I don't care that that much
about how the books look um I'm
interested in what's what's in the books
so I don't really focus on on
that um I'm sort of confused do you
think siblings can be helpful for each
other in terms of artistic or
philosophical growth uh I find the
success of the James Brothers to be
interesting in Hegel and his university
roommates we're talking about like
shelling for example and who they in um
so you know the the examples that you're
giving show that we're not just talking
about siblings but we're talking about
um people that are let's say congenial
to you that you have a close
relationship with so you know the two
James Brothers William and Henry Henry
is known for being a novelist um and
William is known for being a
psychologist and a a philosopher I mean
if you're engaging with a sibling who
you know is is interested in
intellectual and literary and artistic
matters um you can have some great
conversations with them right but you
know hegel's example Hegel he wasn't
like hanging out with his siblings he's
hanging out with his roommates and they
are sharing ing ideas as well this this
is often what happens when you go to
like graduate school or even college
right you meet people and they're
they're into the things that you're into
and then you you connect with them I
mean this can happen
online um I would say the majority of
the people that I interact with pretty
regularly these days in terms of
intellectual matters are not living here
with me in Milwaukee I mean one
exception of course would be my wife um
a few of my colleagues but you know many
of my good friends like you know Mark
SMI down there in South Africa or Harold
cley over in in Norway or you know all
sorts of other people that I interact
with
regularly um and you know bounce ideas
off of and they do that with me you know
um we uh we can do that virtually right
um Harold and I have been in the same
place at the same time exactly one time
in our lives and that was at stoicon
London 2018 where we met up face to face
I've never actually been in the same
place at the same time as Mark Smith um
I met up with my friend Scott Tuli a
guitar professor at Berkeley who I do
the classic metal class with exactly one
time in our lives as well so I think we
can do this now virtually and and you
know having people that uh
you know you you interact with and care
about ideas with yeah that that can be
very
helpful all right AB
um I've been reading N I think it's good
like others you mentioned that at some
point you were somewhat disillusioned by
this philosophy what was it for you um I
wouldn't say disillusioned I just
realized that n like pretty much
everybody else has limitations that
sometimes he get gets um philosophers
and their positions wrong and he does so
often times because he's trying to fit
them into you know a narrative or a
schema or or he misread them you know um
I think that his
uh he's got a lot of really interesting
ideas that are worth
exploring but that um sometimes he can
be a little bit too blanket it's it's
hard for him to resist
coining a phrase like Christianity us
platonism for the masses and you're like
well okay some Christianity might be but
that sure as hell isn't a true statement
about Christianity as a as a
totality you know um so it's things like
that um there's also some incoherences
in his thought but those are sometimes
interesting where you have to explore it
more like think of the genealogy of Mor
morals right everybody talks about the
first essay and the difference between
Master morality and slave morality but
n's thoughts on morality are way more
complicated than that right there's also
the deor Creditor relationship there's
also the development of you know
religious conceptions and bad conscience
that are coming about because of the
strong actually being subordinated not
by the weak but by other strong right
there is the character of the priest who
doesn't fit neatly into that schema
either so you know you got to kind of
explore and see see how it
works uh AE would you encourage someone
to go in chronological order when
reading philosophy and how would you
tackle contemporary works that are based
on older ideas you haven't read yet okay
so two different questions here right um
I mean when people ask like what should
I read I often say start with Playdoh
you know and kind of work your way
forward but but that's just one of many
different ways you can approach
philosophy it's not how I did it you
know um I I read
um existentialist figures and some some
you know at that time fairly recent
stuff like you know finite and infinite
games and things like that that were
philosophical when I was like um out of
high school and working and studying
martialart s before I went in the Army
and then you know in the Army I read a
few things here and there um and maybe I
would have done better if IID started
with Plato I don't know you know I mean
there isn't like a recipe for this sort
of thing um and what should you do with
contemporary works that are based on
older ideas you haven't read yet well I
mean that one's pretty straightforward
if you want to understand what the hell
they're talking about you probably need
to go to those older works right or
you're probably just not going to get
half of what's being being said this is
this is a big problem too you know we we
often teach philosophy as if we can do
all this great High Theory without
having a a background and a basis in the
earlier stuff like you see all these
people you know criticizing cartesianism
and you're like well that's not what
decart actually says so clearly this
person hasn't recently read dayart or
they're being just kind of a pist maybe
maybe we need to actually go back and
see what decart actually says you know
so all right uh I'm sort of confused
says it's fun when you're trying to
interpret a text and think that you're
on to something even think it's helping
you understand some dynamic in the world
then find out you were entirely off
base well you
know if it's actually helping you to
understand some dynamic in the world
then maybe maybe the text wasn't the
right text for it but maybe if you've
actually rightly identified some Dynamic
that exists in the world now you've got
something that you could yourself write
about right um so that could be fun too
um but we often do have you know
experiences like that I mean there's so
many people who I thought I actually
understood when I first read them and
then went back to them later and I'm
like oh man I I didn't understand this
all you know I I I got this wrong uh I
wasn't you know in the right frame of
mind to to read it or you know I mean
stoicism is a great example of that you
know my first encounter with the stoics
was in college I read Marcus aurelius's
meditations and I read um I read uh
epictetus's and cidian and I was like I
don't think this is really for me I you
know I like this toughness part I don't
I don't know what to make of this virtue
talk and
um doesn't seem like a good philosophy
for me and but that's because that the
mindset that I was in at the time which
made me much more willing to like read
sart and and um n and and kard to some
degree although I the religious part of
kard I was like yeah I don't know if if
I buy that right um so this happens a
lot all right uh Canan what are your
thoughts on the science of logic Hegel
not sure why you put it in
quotes um although I do see students
this is a total side note I see students
doing this a lot somehow people get the
idea that the title of a book should be
in quotes that's not the case you put it
in italics right um and you put it in in
all caps
generally um somewhere somebody's
teaching this and I don't know where
students are picking up on this but it
it it's a it's a weird way of doing
things
um what are my thoughts on the science
of logic it's a real headcracker of a a
work you know very
complicated um a lot some people will
tell you that they perfectly understand
the relationship between the
phenomenology of Spirit and the science
of logic it's not quite so simple in in
my point of view some there's parts that
like line up with each other and then a
lot of parts that don't there's a lot of
cool stuff in the science of logic but
um you know I don't know that
that it's necessarily worth the time to
spend working through it I will say this
in the 19th century and the early 20th
century um the science of logic the Phil
philosophy of right and the encyclopedia
logic were much more widely read than
was the phenomenology of spirit and that
changed in the 20th century largely I
would say because of uh French and
German scholarship and and teaching on
on Hegel you know so less people read
the um the science of logic today than
read the phenomenology of spirit but you
know it's a great book um you just got
to decide whether it's worth the time
that you're gonna have to spend on
it um Mahammad says uh thanks for your
work what constitutes a good life in
your own opinion
um I mean I would say I'm pretty
Aristotelian in that respect I think the
life of virtuous activity you know which
means that you actually have to develop
some some degree of the virtues which
means you actually have to like figure
out what the virtues actually are um and
that takes a lot of doing we don't just
want to have I pointed out in videos
recently with Alistar McIntyre we don't
want to just use virtue language without
knowing what the hell we're talking
about um and you know you do need to
have some modum of of wealth especially
in the economy that we live in today um
and relationships are incredibly
important you know I think that we could
add some other components to that and
widen the scope a bit you know our
bodily Health which Aristotle does talk
about is is important you know um we do
want to think about what our Legacy is
and what kind of world we're leaving
behind and a good life could be one
that's devoted to making things better
for human beings or even for animals um
now you know the second question my view
of Peter singer's view that Ordinary
People are evil I'm not sure where
that's coming from um I don't I don't
recall a place where Peter Singer just
Flatout says Ordinary People are
evil
um but uh I mean there's a lot of things
that he thinks that in our contemporary
way of approaching things are
bad um you know he's he's
uh he's devoted to animal Liberation and
rights and so like in so far as most of
us participate in a food system that
involves a lot of suffering for animals
um maybe that's what you have in mind
there but it's not like he says we can
just simply abandon that you
know all right
um Dan the man says I'm teaching
asynchronous philosophy courses next
spring at a community college going to
be intro to philosophy and intro to
ethics do you have any tips or advice um
yeah so when we say asynchronous just
for the people out there who aren't
familiar with this terminology what we
mean are classes that are not only
online but they don't have class
meetings at a given time every week
right so like I'm actually teaching a
online synchronous religions of the
world class next semester for Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design we will be
meeting on Mondays and I forget whether
it's at 12:30 or maybe
3:15 um but we'll like you know meet
using uh Google meets but we can meet
using Zoom or anything like that so
asynchronous
classes they may proceed like on a
weekly schedule um but you're not
meeting weekly and so there's some
challenges involved with
that one is um making sure that the
students engage each other in a regular
fashion and so that's that's why you use
like discussion
forms and discussion forms can be set up
well you want open-ended questions that
they really have to think about you want
them complex enough so that their
initial post isn't just yeah I agree or
something like that
um and
[Music]
um you know you you want to make sure
they're engaging each other and and you
want to give them something about
netiquette so they don't act like jerks
to each other and if you see them acting
like jerks get in there early on and you
got to read the discussion forums right
you can't just let them go at it um and
you you'll also maybe see instances of
plagiarism in discussion forums I've had
students who've copied each other's
forums in the past you know maybe they
thought the instructor wasn't paying
attention I mean it's so easy to tell
right um and then you know think about
the other kinds of assignments that you
want to make sure the students are
engaging the work and then think about
the resources that you're going to
provide them
so
um videos are very helpful as a matter
of fact it's recommended by quality
matters which is like the organization
that does a lot of good certification
for online classes that you should have
what we call framing videos for the
class and for each week and a framing
video is nice and short you say hey
students welcome to the
class here's what we're going to be
doing you know you might want a video
like that for uh each one of the major
kinds of assignments that you have like
discussion forums make a video because
students students really benefit from
the engagement with the instructor even
in video format
right um so you're saying like here's
what I'm looking for in discussion
forums right and it doesn't have to be
perfect as a matter of fact like look at
this background right students are fine
with it being kind of a just a regular
lived in background doesn't have to be
beautiful you don't have to have scripts
or anything but you do want to have um
stuff that they can like feel engaged
with and and try to provide them with
lecture videos or podcast episodes
or um you know good blog posts
or um handouts or or things like that LE
You Know lesson pages on the material
that you're going to be studying and it
doesn't have to be perfect that's that's
the last bit of advice that I'll give
you it doesn't have to be perfect in
order to be good for your students
so all right JM Canon where would you
suggest starting with Young I wouldn't
I'm not I'm not into young
so uh let's see here uh just skipped up
a little bit
[Music]
um boki did you ever read Evol uh illan
cough I have
not um mm what do you think think of the
folkish movement in the thinkers of the
conservative revolution of the 30s of
the previous Century I think they're
full of crap and uh you know mainly went
in the wrong directions um so Jefferson
Oro can you speak of your religious
journey in life um yeah I mean I've I've
always been you could say thinking about
like cosmological and
metaphysical issues throughout my life I
was raised um here in in Wisconsin I'm
pointing that way because I was raised
about 30 miles to the west of
here in a area that at that time was
kind of country kind of Rural and um you
know I went to Catholic church because
my my parents were catholic my dad kind
of nominally so uh my mom perhaps a
little bit more
devout um and
um just about everybody I knew is either
Catholic or Lutheran or Presbyterian and
if they if they were Presbyterian they
were from the the village of Wales
because that's where we had the the
Presbyterians um and you know nobody
really knew anything they made you go to
What's called CCD which is catechesis
and Christian doctrine once a week and
that was pretty piss poor as far as
actual catak cases so you know by the
time that I got into High School
um I kind of and I was going to Catholic
High School I was kind of like this is a
BS none of this really matters much you
know the people that are teaching the
religion classes don't really know much
of anything and I left the church you
know and um they were so cool back then
that they were like yeah you don't have
to stand up in Mass you can protest if
you want you know that's fine and then
um later on in life um you know I'd
still go to mass every once in a while
with my family because it was a family
thing you know but I didn't you know I
wasn't particularly interested and I was
you know studying people like nche and
sart and uh even deart nominally
Christian not really a Christian he's
more of a deist um and so you know that
went on for quite a while and then I
ended up um interestingly reading uh
people like Thomas aquinus and anom of
Canterbury to work on my Latin and I
found that they had really great depth
of thought and I started reading more
and more people and particularly getting
into the works of Maurice Blondell and
um other other similar thinkers and
found my way back to it um I'm not happy
with what the what what's happened in
the American Catholic Church in terms of
right-wingers essentially taking over
large parts of it uh and getting too
involved in culture wars rather than
actual you know sacramental religion
um you know and and there's other issues
as well that I think are real problems
so you can say I'm wrestling with God
you know uh throughout my My Life um and
you know I think that the I I really
like reading religious thinkers
particularly the ones as I've said many
times for whom uh becoming religious
didn't solve any of their problems it
didn't answer all their questions it
just made things more complicated and in
some respects more pressing in terms of
questions that had to be sorted out
so um ultimate artist what are your
thoughts on wokeness I think anybody who
talks about wokeness is stupid or a
grifter you know wasting all of our time
and there is a there is a woke mind
virus out there but it's the anti-woke
Mind virus the people who obsess about
wokness and you know it give it another
three years and that term will have
dropped out of our vocabul
just like postmodern you know blah blah
blah uh you know and um pick whatever
else you you want uh conservatives these
days are not conservative at all because
they can't even like retain the same
vocabulary from year to year to year
about the stuff that they get their
panties and a bunch about so that's my
thoughts about
that
um Sean Costello criticizing
cartesianism spot on um I I you know I
assume you mean like saying if you're
going to criticize cartesianism you
actually have to know what deart says
Muhammad says is political philosophy
the same as political theory if yes then
what is the real difference well if yes
then there isn't a real difference right
if no what is the real difference and
the answer is sort of like the one I
gave about existentialism and absurdism
prior um they they overlap I mean you
you could think of political Theory as
being part of political philosophy or
either either way you know um but there
isn't like a strict dividing line
between the the two of
them all right
um let's see here oh ken good to see you
is there a particular translation of
dialogues and essays by senica that you
would
recommend um you
know there isn't an addition of
dialogues and essays um at called such
but there is there are some newer
translations that University of Chicago
press published uh a while back and so
they've got you know the letters to
lilus in in one volume and then there's
um a bunch of other volumes like on
benefits is another whole volume because
that's a long
book and then there's one called
Happiness and hardship that has a lot of
the essays in it that are that are quite
good like um on the happy life on
shortness of life you know the
consolations and all that sort of stuff
there's another one called anger
Mercy uh Revenge which has on anger and
on clemency in it so I mean I think
those I mean they can be a little pricey
because they're newer books but I think
those are really the good ones a lot of
noise outside are doing some some
construction stuff I don't know if you
hear that but uh it it seems to be
pretty
loud um so ultimate artist looks like
they're being kind of a jerk on here so
uh I guess uh it's time
to remove them it's too
bad um because you
know you don't want to be a jerk on
somebody else's front porch you know uh
Caleb says I'm a psychotherapist and
find that my most satisfying sessions
are those that turn into a philosophical
edification of sorts just want to let
you know I refer folks to your channel
frequently well that that's good I mean
you know
Psychotherapy um there's and you
probably have seen this there's a
tendency for people to like turn it into
a bunch of techniques this is the big
danger with the cognitive Revolution
that's happened in you know the last say
half century um you know Freud Freud in
approaches psychoanalysis were
dominating for a long time and then the
cognitive behavior you know rebt CBT DBT
all these these cognitive approaches
wound up um essentially replacing it and
talking about how they could you know um
beat everybody else out and they were
evidence-based and all that but it but
it easily turns into when it's not being
done in a thoughtful way just a bunch of
um techniques and we don't want to do
that we want to bring something like you
know a philosophical approach to dealing
with people's psyches because they're
pretty damn complicated right and
there's a lot of different factors
involved you know so that's that's
that's great to to read
um all right uh Gilbert bat started
digging into being and nothingness I
like it a lot there's a lot of
interesting ideas but it's tough
goinging it fries your brain is there
some particular idea that you find
interesting oh yeah I mean early on uh
s's ideas about the for itself and the
in itself which he takes you know um
that's sort of hegelian language but
he's doing a very different thing than
Hegel did with it in in like the
phenomenology and this is part of what I
found so attractive about sart being in
nothingness was like the first big
philosophy book that I read my way
through and I did that as an
undergraduate um and I thought it was it
was just brilliant now of course I see
some shortcomings but
um yeah the idea that human freedom is
so free that it cannot be defined into
just one thing or another uh and that
that is part of what it is to to be a
being for itself I think that's really
kind of a brilliant insight on on his
part um Luke says how would you answer
someone who argues that conservative
academics are censured or prevented from
winning funding I have a hard time
responding to conspiratorial thinking
don't respond to it don't engage with it
I mean if people want to be crackpots
and whine about all sorts of
non-existent problems I mean has any
conservative ever been turned down for
funding but on the basis of being a
conservative sure I mean you can find
anybody any sort of status there's
people who' have been turned down for
funding because their hair was too long
or Too Short or you know somebody didn't
like the way that they looked or
something like that
but anybody who knows anything about
Academia knows that all of this
conservative whining and bitching and
belly aing about how they're there
there's no place for them in Academia is
just a bunch of
like exactly that whining you know
um there's plenty of room for it because
there's plenty of conservatives out
there in Academia you know I know some
of them and uh what people don't like
are lazy entitled whiners and that's
unfortunately what most people who call
themselves conservatives these days
actually turn out to be it's really
quite sad because again conservatives
did not manage to conserve anything good
about conservativism
so yeah all right
um so mm has some clarification about
the Peter Singer thing uh it is in a
thumbnail by a YouTuber and the video is
concerned with a controversial essay on
morality by singer the title is
provocative my guy built upon it yeah
there you go you know so not the real
thing but uh rather
um you know um
a a mistaken view on singer done
specifically to try to get some clout
out there in YouTube
so yeah there you go all right uh
impulsive you've said previously that
Kira
guards uh the concept of anxiety isn't
the most Illuminating text on the topic
of anxiety he wrote which work would you
say is the best for that I didn't say
that that it's not the the most
Illuminating text on the topic of
anxiety
I I think I probably said it's probably
not the most Illuminating text read it
you know then read uh the sickness on to
death and read
um um fear and trembling I mean why do
you fear and tremble because you're
living in anxiety right so you know
there's there's a number of ones uh
Zachary any tips on acquiring
recommendation letters for grad school
have you written any for students I have
written some for students in the P I
typically don't anymore because you know
I'm an adjunct so I'm I'm not usually
teaching students in their major
classes and I'm not getting to build a
relationship with students over a long
time right so if they're coming to me
for a letter for letter of
recommendation I'm like you need to be
reaching out to people who know you
better and can say something more about
about your studies right uh not me now
there are exceptions to that you know
I've I I've written uh letters of
recommendation for young um high school
students who' have studied with me
extensively over the course of years um
as private tutorials right but
um I think what you want to do is you
want to think about okay who knows you
well well enough to comment on the
things that people would actually care
about in terms of your application so
people who can say yeah this
person really gets their work done on
time and up to standards and is
thoughtful about it and here are some
things that I've noticed about them over
the years so you want you want to think
about who can actually write you a good
letter of recommendation a letter of
recommendation that tells people about
who you are and if you don't have any
Now's the Time to start making those
connections before you hit them up for
the letter because otherwise they might
be like I don't really know you I don't
know what I would say you
know all right uh blank
name uh how would you deal with Envy of
other people I notice when somebody is
envious of something I have I feel bad I
know I also get envious sometimes well I
mean you want to think about precisely
that why do you feel bad when somebody
else who's none of your damn business
gets envious about something that you
have why do you let that affect you
what's your thought process what's going
on with that and then once you actually
start figuring that out and making it
manifest for yourself then you can you
know start deciding whether it's
rational or not for you to be bothered
by other people being envious of you um
and whether you get envious of other
people or not doesn't have anything to
do with the question of you feeling bad
about about them being envious of you um
those are two separate issues I mean who
doesn't get envious of somebody about
something right
um but that that doesn't have to turn
into US feeling bad because somebody
else happens to have this emotion
towards what what we
have um awful philosophy I've been
getting into phenomenology and cannot
reconcile hustel and haiger feels like
they're doing very different things any
advice yeah don't reconcile Hil and
haiger nobody says that you have to they
are doing different things as a matter
fact not only are hell and haiger doing
different things so is edit Stein so is
Maurice merap Ponte so is MOX shayer
just to name several other important um
phenomenologists of that time they're
all doing different things because there
is no one single thing out there called
phenomenology that they all buy into
there's a pH phenomenological movement
which is very broad sort of like
existentialism which by the way lot of
overlap between phenomenology and
existentialism some phenomenologists are
existentialists some Phenom
phenomenologists are not some
existentialists are phenomenologists
some existentialists are not right so
you don't have to reconcile these these
uh thinkers with each other just try to
figure out what the hell they're
actually saying and then be okay with
comparing and
contrasting uh them with with each other
you
know um Joseph says if you were to learn
philosophy chronologically who are the
main philosophers of each major era you
would focus on the most kind of depends
on what you consider to be major eras
right um I mean we often distinguish
between like helenic philosophy and
helenistic philosophy but Aristotle
should actually be in helenistic because
you know he's writing in the time after
the Greek city state has basically come
to an end um you know Plato Aristotle if
you want to study ancient philosophy
Cicero is very important and you get a
lot of other great stuff through him
Sena for the stoics obviously and epicus
you know um we don't have much from the
epicureans unfortunately but you want to
read what's available sexus empiricus
for the the skeptic
um then we get into all this you know
late Antiquity early medieval you know
Augustine beus John Cassian we could go
on and on and on and on and on right
there's you probably there isn't a main
philosophers of each major era that you
would focus on the most because that's
part of what you're trying to figure out
as you're going through it
right all right uh impulsive says uh
speaking of phenomenology are you
interested in levas at all not much I
mean I had to read levas in graduate
school he was a big deal back then um
you know I kind of got turned off by the
lonians that were out there because all
they ever wanted to do was talk about
the face of the other and how we have fa
the other and we can never truly do
justice to the other and other other
other other other other other and I
think they ignore the other stuff in
levinas that was interesting and if you
can't really have a good conversation
with people about the philosophers that
you're interested in and you can study
other
philosophers why are you g to spend time
on that that thinker and and I say that
as somebody who actually studied with
somebody who was one of the earliest
English translators of leviness GTH
Gillan who worked with Alfonso Lingus
and eventually withdrew from the
project but who was very very interested
in in in leving us but who also saw this
problem with
levians
so um I mean maybe if I have time I'll
go back and reread you know some of
levinas's works but I got so much other
stuff going on that I think other people
could maybe do that instead you know uh
we don't always all have to read the
same people so all right Nolan says if
you ever read Solitude by Anthony store
I don't even know who Anthony store is
so whether he's a philosopher literary
figure or something like that so no I I
haven't read him sad to
say
um do you have Pros maybe do you think
philosophy matters at all in all ma
matters at all in major real scenes of
Life conflicts and political Arena where
are the philosophers especially ethics
experts having their voices heard well
these are two totally different
questions
right where are the philosophers
moralists ethics experts having their
voices heard where people are reading
them or listening to them I mean all you
got to do is spend a little bit of time
out there and you're going to find
philosophers uh saying things about all
sorts of interesting topics right but
it's not as if people are um jumping
over themselves to bring in philosophers
to talk about the late
incident in international politics even
though they could right and that's in
part because uh the people who are
um you know the people who are uh
engaging in opinion formation generally
haven't studied much philosophy or if
they did they studied with people who
weren't very good at it you know but is
is uh does philosophy matter in scenes
of Life conflicts and the political
Arena of course I mean people are always
doing philosophy it's very often bad
philosophy um but you can be studying
philosophy and bringing it in in ways
that Ordinary People can appreciate and
it's part of what I do in my career
right I've been doing that for um more
than a decade with re and iio in sort of
an official capacity doing like ethics
Consulting for organizations and you
know Executive coaching that's all doing
philosophy stuff you know so
all right uh box 23 how important is the
school I attend for a master's in
philosophy there's no there's no like
definitive answer to that it depends on
the program that you're applying to for
a masters like I mentioned earlier
hundreds of them that you could apply to
here in the United States and they all
have different standards and they're all
going to go through a different
procedure in deciding whether to let you
in or not so that is the sort of
question that you need to ask ask The
Graduate um student advisor or what you
know graduate admissions advisor for the
schools that you're applying to and you
might get very different answers and
they may lie to you about these these
questions as well you know
so all right
um David marzo says are you familiar
with the consolation of philosophy
buthus no tell me more about that I mean
I did shoot a sequence of videos on
boethus and I did give a talk in the
philosophers in the midst of History uh
sequence on boethus if I'm not mistaken
but maybe maybe I I've never heard of
that guy ever in my
life uh what do you think uh blank name
did you read most of the philosophers
you've read while in school or what when
you got out of grad
school um I'd say probably I've read
more since I got out of grad school but
you got to remember that I finished
graduate school over 20 years ago in
2002 so I've been out in the field
working um reading teaching writing all
that sort of stuff for two decades you
know so there's quite a few people who I
um you know I may some of them I I read
in graduate school but didn't read as
much you know great example of that
would be Emanuel Kant right I mean you
had to read kant's um first critique
second critique groundwork for the
metaphysics of morals proma just to take
your preliminary examinations right um
and I read some other stuff like
religion within the limits of reason
alone and I read the metaph metaphysics
of morals too um oh and the anthropology
from a pragmatic point of view but I've
read some of those
subsequently and realized that the
reading that I had in graduate school
school might not have been quite so so
good you know
um so uh I think there there's a lot of
um things that I read after graduate
school and then there's quite a few that
I deepened my reading of or I widened my
my reading
of um Joseph says uh the Youtube
algorithm just showed me your cat sassy
munching on your food what an appetite
yeah she was she was a very food
motivated animal as they call them right
she was a great cat she was also very
pushy she was the top animal in our
house and that included two uh dogs one
of whom was over a 100 pounds at her her
Peak she was 120 pounds the other one
was I think topped off actually at
105 um at his Peak as well and she would
boss them around you know because uh she
she uh was an adult when they were
puppies so all right Rexel uh what is
the frontier philosophical studies right
now much like what Theory of Everything
Is for physics if there is any there
isn't any I mean that's all [__]
stuff anybody who tells you this is The
Cutting Edge this is the
frontier there isn't one single thing
like that there's all sorts of things
happening and nobody has like a complete
comprehensive view on it because there's
like tens of thousands of people doing
philosophical work in interesting ways
at this point in time even with physics
most people aren't working on a Theory
of Everything most people are doing you
know basic uh research stuff uh in this
area this area this area you know so
David says are those videos available on
YouTube I don't know enough to feel
comfortable to comment I mean all you
got to do any YouTube channel you just
go into the channel and then you use the
search function and you can see what
anybody has it's uh super easy to do
or you can just type in Gregory Sadler
buus and you'll you'll see the videos
come up in in Google as well uh Buren uh
says writings of Hegel and such
philosophers are so complex any
guidelines for reading them well you
know I've got videos on how to do
self-directed study on Hegel um so you
might want to watch that
video and see what it what it recommends
for you um but yeah philosophy is
complicated actually anything at a high
level is
complicated um be willing to deal with
it being difficult and complicated and
having to go over it multiple times and
make your best attempt at it you know um
use secondary sources when you find that
they're helpful make sure that that
doesn't distract you from actually
reading the text itself and that's about
it that we can we can
say um de proos says when studying
philosophical literature did you have a
reading debating group or an adversary
to hone your understanding and
philosophical skills I think adversaries
and debates are highly overrated it's a
great way to get drawn into personality
conflicts and one upmanship rather than
actual study and I think this not just
for philosophy but for many other things
um you can hone your skills in many ways
that are not
antagonistic and focusing on the
antagonistic will probably result in you
developing certain skills and not
developing others um sometimes we had
reading groups I mean oftentimes we had
classes I I took graduate level classes
for example on you know lud Vicken Stein
and teodor dorno and you know Hegel and
n and uh Marlo ponti and all all these
other interesting thinkers and then we
also did have reading groups like we had
a KAG guard reading group for a while we
had a Hegel reading group uh that spent
an entire year going through the
phenomenology of spirit um what else did
we do reading groups on oh
dissur languis General a bunch of other
things as well and that can be nice
right if the other people are actually
doing the reading if they have something
to bring to it uh working on things
together can be quite
helpful uh Zachary do you think virtue
is a skill that could be developed no
it's not a skill
it's a disposition and it's not a
disposition it is an entire set of
dispositions there is virtue the generic
term and then there are the virtues
plural right so um if so could the truly
virtuous agent make decisions just like
an expert and could this be how The
Virtuous agent just knows what's right
there's analogies but it's not it's not
a skill and and even real expertise is
not just a skill either it's disposition
not knowledge narrative all these other
things brought together right so you
want to avoid trying to have a a sort of
reductive view on on what the virtues
are um Rea I started the academic study
of ba philosophy at the age of 41 do you
think I have the intellectual capacity
to make it to the
PHD I wouldn't know because I don't know
you you know um it it's not just a
matter of intellectual capacity it's all
Al a matter of having the ability to um
you know take the time to intensively
study things and having the
opportunities to to do that I mean if
you're working a regular job you're
probably not going to do a PhD you know
even if you are motivated and
intellectually capable of it um there's
a lot of different uh uh ramifications
to that uh
um all right uh let's see well getting
close to the time let's see if we can
take somebody who hasn't
um said something actually I'm going do
a followup on Reza so the fact of age
and dwindling intellectual power there's
nothing about age that means you're
having dwindling intellectual power as a
matter of fact a lot of the great
philosophy stuff is done by people in
their 40s 50s 60s 7s 80s look at alist
MC
or Jurgen habas still working in their
90s you know um there's nothing that
says that you know you're gonna have
dwindling intellectual power as a matter
of fact um you can find as as many
people do that you're actually better
off in your middle age than down the
line all right
so let's see
here vegan sports bar do you think it's
POS possible to work a full-time job and
self-study philosophy or am I screwed
yeah it's possible I mean you just have
to decide what you want to do you know
the time that you're studying philosophy
you're not spending watching shows on
Netflix or you know bullshitting around
in a bar or something like that you know
it's certainly possible uh I I mean I
did it I I worked full-time jobs when I
wasn't in graduate school actually more
than full-time and and studied
philosophy and studied languages um but
you know you're going to have to make
certain sacrifices it's going to take
discipline and and all of that
so
um all right so let's
see Orville 999 if the Athenians
considered piety so important why did
they execute Socrates even though the
Oracle of Deli said he was the wisest of
the Greeks so the Oracle of Deli didn't
say he was is the wisest of the Greeks
this is why it's really important to pay
close attention to what's actually said
and not rely upon sort of like glosses
on it what does it actually say in the
apology what did the Oracle tell kiraan
according to
Socrates is there anyone wiser than
Socrates
no that doesn't mean he's the wisest
that just means there's nobody
wiser and why would the Athenians give a
[__] what Socrates tells in his story I
mean anybody could make up a story like
that on the spot I mean you want to you
want to think these things through in a
non-abstract kind of way right so all
right
um let's see we've got
uh bunch of back and forth here about
[Music]
um about pure being and Hegel which I'm
going to skip
over um
let's see if there's a good one to go
out
on
[Music]
um so vegan sports bar do you think
Plato would have allowed heavy metal for
the soldiers but not for the
masses Plato's not worried so much in
the Republic uh
about the style of music he's interested
in the modes because he he thinks of
them and so does Aristotle by the way in
politics I want to say book seven things
that the different modes encourage
different kinds of emotional
responses and um you might be right
about that I think it's a little bit too
too reductionist
um you know and there heavy metal names
a lot of different things so it it
depends on who you're talking about if
we're just sticking to like what we call
Classic heavy metal from the 70s and
80s uh maybe play
would have let the auxiliaries or the
you know the fighting troops have some
of that but um probably would have yeah
probably would have discouraged it for
the masses but um the worry would be
about it getting our thumos too too
riled up and interestingly one of the
things that we found through research is
that people who regularly listen to
heavy metal often um the music doesn't
make them like Ang Ang rer more
aggressive um it it helps to like
stabilize their mood and sometimes calm
them down so so that's a good place to
end here
um so uh got a bunch of other things
people still going on about uh
um being and nothingness and stuff like
that remember too that with that Hegel
is using terminology very often
differently than other people are are
using it so that that might be helpful
in thinking that that question through
all right so I got to go because I got
to eat some lunch and then I've got
another event I've got to do for patreon
supporters so I will see all of you um
somewhere else in the ether thanks for
all the good questions and and comments
um and we got a lot of other cool stuff
coming up in the following weeks you can
always go to the channel to find that
out or you can find stuff in the reason
IO events calendar or by going to my
Facebook page where I I tend to post
events as well uh if you're in the
Milwaukee area I'm going to be speaking
at the Frank wanberg library on
Wednesday doing a Philosophers in the
midst of history about David Hume
so and then uh we come up to
Thanksgiving at least here in the states
so that'll be fun as well so I will see
all of you and uh take it easy on your
end